when you decide to settle down will you
ask her what happened but it'll be that
question will be somehow incorporated
into a load of questions in the stage of
talking it won't be something I asked
six months in
um that will def that that will be a
building block to me depending whether I
go further this person yeah so it does
matter to you then of course of course
it matters it's a single digits of
course of course nine is the top listen
listen if you said to me right now you
said if you said to me me and you just
meet at a bar and with no flirtation
between us we're just talking you said
to me randomly a conversation come up
you said I'll set with 50 guys I would
not judge you one bit but would you wipe
her no but let's no it's nowhere near